Hello, my name is Glenn Loury.
I'm the Merton Stoltz professor of the Social Sciences
at Brown University and professor of Economics there,
and I've been writing for many years
about the issues of race and inequality
in the United States.
I'm here to talk about race in America,
with particular emphasis on the black family.
I just wanna share with you some thoughts that I prepared
for this occasion.
I wanna talk about the fact of historical
African-American subordination.
I wanna say what it means for American citizenship,
and I wanna consider some possible solutions
to this longstanding dilemma.
The priority of social relations
before economic transactions is my theme.
But don't worry, I'll not be masquerading as a sociologist
or a political theorist.
Rather, I'm gonna draw on my many years of study
as an economist and a public intellectual
to briefly make two observations
and then draw some conclusions.
One about the dynamics of human development
and the other about the foundations of racial identity.
I will bring this back to the theme of the black family
in conclusion.
"Now, why?" I ask.
The success of the Civil Rights Movement not withstanding
has the subordinate status of African-Americans persisted
in the 21st century.
Clear thinking about this intractable problem
requires one to distinguish the role played
by discrimination against black people
from the role of counterproductive patterns of behavior
that can be found within African-American society.
Now, I admit that this puts what is a very sensitive issue,
rather starkly.
Many vocal advocates of racial equality
refuse even to consider the possibility
that problematic behavior could be an important factor
contributing to the persisting disadvantage of blacks.
At the same time,
some observers on the right of American politics
insists that anti-black discrimination
is no longer an important determinant
of unequal social outcomes.
I've tried to chart a middle course
acknowledging anti-black biases that should be remedied,
but insisting on the imperative of addressing
and reversing the behavior patterns
preventing some blacks from seizing
newly opened opportunities.
Among these behavior patterns are gonna be the interactions
between men and women within the context
of family formation, childbearing, and child rearing.
This is an explosive topic in American political culture.
I can remember within my own lifetime
when Daniel Patrick Moynihan's report was first issued
in 1965, "The Negro Family: The Case for National Action"
he called it.
He argued then with 25% of black children
being born to a woman without a husband
that this problem was gonna stand as a fundamental barrier
to black progress.
And indeed, if it weren't somehow dealt with
might prevent the fruit of the Civil Rights Movement
successes from being enjoyed fully by African-Americans
and by the country.
He was pilloried for daring to raise the question
as a white man.
And since then,
a political discussion about this question
has been stifled and truncated.
People have been wary to raise the issues
and to talk about these themes.
They don't wanna be accused of blaming the victim.
They don't wanna seem to be judgmental.
They don't wanna be imposing a moral calculus
on the lives of people,
especially people who have been victimized by discrimination
and who may be plagued by poverty.
This, I think, is a mistake.
What was 25% when Moynihan was calling his call to arms
was issuing his call to arms over a half century ago.
It's 70% now.
The African-American family, one could say,
is in deep trouble.
Again, there will be pushback.
People will say, "Why do you judge family by a single norm?"
They will say, "It takes a village to raise a child.
Why should we think in terms of patrimony,"
patriarchy, I should say,
in terms of the nuclear family is the only model.
I don't wanna waste my time with those arguments.
I simply wanna call attention to the needs of young people
that have stable social foundations
within the context of which they can mature
and realize their human potential.
And I wanna say that a mother and father raising children
is a sounder foundation to that end
than as a mother raising those children alone.
I'll have more to say about that in due course.
But let me return to the framework
that I wanna try to elaborate for you
by discussing those two observations.
These two positions can be recast as causal narratives.
One I'm gonna call the biased narrative.
Racism and white supremacy have done this wrong.
We can't get ahead until they relent,
so we must continue urging reform on American society
toward that end.
The other narrative I'm gonna call
the development narrative.
Emphasizing the need to consider how people come to acquire
those skills, traits, habits, and orientations
that foster an individual's successful participation
in American society.
To the extent that black youngsters
do not have the experiences,
are not exposed to the influences,
and do not benefit from the resources
that foster and facilitate their human development
to that extent,
they may fail to achieve their full potential.
It is this lack of development
that ultimately causes the stark racial disparities
in income, wealth, education,
and much else to persist,
so goes the development narrative.
So we have two narratives,
the bias narrative and the development narrative.
We have two basic approaches to the problem
of persisting racial inequality.
To assume that it's the consequences of discrimination
or to understand that, at least in part,
is the result of the failure of many African-Americans
to realize their full human potential.
I wanna emphasize this latter narrative
as being more relevant to our present day.
And I wanna call attention to the role of the family
as a part of the larger developmental matrix
which either fosters or impedes the potential
for achievement for black people in America.
These two narratives, of course,
need not be mutually exclusive.
But in terms of prescribing interventions and remedies,
they point in very different directions.
The bias narrative urges us to,
well, to have a conversation about race.
White America must reform itself.
Racism must end.
We need more of this or more of that,
whatever the this or the that is on the agenda
of today's social justice warriors.
One can hear this kind of talk and read these exhortations
in newspapers and other media daily.
The development narrative,
alternatively, puts more onus on the responsibilities
of African-Americans to develop our human potential.
Not on our own to be sure,
not without the support and the assistance
of whatever social programs the society should decide
are justified.
But nevertheless, ultimately,
the responsibility for raising one's children into maturity
rests on the parents of those children first and foremost.
The development narrative is not satisfied
with wishful thinking,
like if we could only double the budget for some social
program than the homicide rate among young black men
would be less atrocious.
Or if we could just get the local police department
investigated by the U.S Department of Justice,
then...
"Then what?" the development narrative wants to ask.
Then it will become possible to walk on the south side
of Chicago after midnight?
I am one social scientist who finds that
to be an extremely dubious claim.
So, what are my two observations?
Over four decades ago in my doctoral dissertation at MIT,
I had the good fortune to coin the term social capital.
I did so by way of contrasting my concept,
social capital, with what economists then
traditionally called human capital.
As you may know,
human capital theory imports into the study
of human inequality and intellectual framework
which had been developed primarily
to explain investment decisions by firms,
a framework that focuses on the analysis
of formal economic transactions.
In my thesis, I argued that this framework was inadequate
to the problem of accounting for social inequality.
Please, allow me to explain.
My fundamental point was that associating business
and human investments is merely an analogy, not an identity,
particularly if one seeks to explain
persistent racial disparities.
Business investments are transactional.
Human investments are essentially relational.
So important things are overlooked
in the human capital approach,
things having to do with informal social relations,
such as those which occur inside of families.
Human capital theory is incomplete
when it comes to explaining racial disparities, I argued.
There are two central aspects of this incompleteness
and thus my two observations about the dynamics
of human development and the nature of racial identity.
Permit me to explain.
First, I stress that all human development
is socially situated and mediated.
That is, I argued that the development of human beings
occurs inside of social institutions.
It takes place as between people
by way of human interaction,
the family, the community, the school, the peer group,
these cultural institutions of human association
are where development is achieved,
resources essential to human development.
The attention that a parent gives to her child,
for instance, are not alienable.
Developmental resources, for the most part,
are not commodities.
The development of human beings is largely not up for sale.
Rather, structured connections between individuals
create the context within which developmental resources
come to be allocated to individual persons.
I ask you to forgive me.
I speak like an economist.
I talk about resources and I talk about allocations.
I can't help myself.
I am an economist.
But bear with me because these categories are,
I think, useful as a conceptual framework
for talking about the problem of inequality,
which is what I am intending to talk about here today.
Opportunity travels along the synapsis of social networks.
The development of human beings is not the same
as corporate investment,
and so, it need not be a good metaphor or a good analogy
to reason as though this were so.
People are not machines.
Their productivities, that is to say,
the behavioral and cognitive capacities
bearing on their social and economic function,
these things are not merely the result
of a mechanical infusion of material resources.
Redistributing money doesn't necessarily fix the problem
when these things are in deficit.
Rather, the capacities to develop human beings
are the byproducts of social processes
that are mediated by networks of human affiliation
and connectivity.
This was fundamentally important, I thought,
and still think,
for understanding persistent racial disparities in America.
And that's why I coined the term social capital
in order to emphasize the difference between the benefits
to human development that flow from social connectivity
and those benefits that flow from monetary resources.
That's the first point that I wanted to make
all those years ago
about the incompleteness of human capital theory.
Now, my second observation was that what we are calling race
in America is mainly a social
and only indirectly a biological phenomenon.
Mind you now, I'm talking about racial inequality in America
and the black family.
So I'm talking about inequality and I'm talking about race.
My first observation was an observation about inequality.
Inequality in human development
because of the way that social networks either do or do not
deliver the relations that are necessary
in order for people to flourish and reach their potential.
Now I wanna talk about race.
And in America, that is not only,
but it is substantially in our history,
a matter of black and white.
And so, as I go forward,
I will talk about race in somewhat binary terms,
which is not entirely descriptive of the complex demographic
landscape that we inhabit here in the 21st century
in the United States of America,
but what should be a useful starting point
for thinking about the problem of racial inequality
and persisting black disadvantage,
which is the subject of this lecture.
So, my second observation was that what we're calling race
in America is mainly a social
and only indirectly a biological phenomenon.
The persistence across generations of racial differentiation
between large groups of people in an open society
where individuals live in close proximity to one another
provides irrefutable indirect evidence of a profound
separation between the racially defined social networks
of affiliation within that society.
That was a somewhat complicated sentence,
so let me try to put it more directly.
There would be no races in the study state of any dynamic
social system unless on a daily basis,
and in regard to their most intimate affairs,
people paid very close attention to the boundaries
that separate themselves from racially distinct others.
Over time, that is,
race, in inverted commas,
would cease to exist unless people chose to act in a manner
so as biologically to reproduce the variety
of phenotypic expression that constitutes the subject
of racial distinction.
Again, a complex sentence packed with ideas
that are important to the subject of our discussion
here right now.
I can't overemphasize the point I'm trying to make
at this moment.
What we're calling race is not something that is given
in nature.
Rather it is a social product.
It's an equilibrium outcome.
It's something that we, collectively,
within the society are making and remaking over time.
It is, as we economists like to say,
an indogenous outcome.
It follows that if the goal is to understand the roots
of durable racial inequality,
one needs to attend, in some detail,
to the processes that cause race to persist as a fact
in the society under study
because those processes, almost certainly,
will not be unrelated to the allocation
of developmental resources in that society.
Again, I need to apologize for being an economist.
I'm talking about the allocation of developmental resources.
My first point was that that depends on how people
are located relative to each other within social networks.
It depends upon relations.
But I'm also talking about racial inequality.
And my second observation is that depends on how people
in that society behave in terms of their most intimate
social relations with one another
because without mating patterns that are largely
within racial groups,
the very fact of distinct races within the society
would fade away and wither away over time.
So those are the two observations that I wanna make
as a foundation for carrying forward my argument
about the black family.
Here then is my second observation in a nutshell.
The creation and reproduction of race as a social reality
in any society rests on cultural conceptions about identity
that are embraced by people,
blacks and whites alike, in that society.
These are the convictions people affirm
about who they are and about the legitimacy
of conducting intimate relations
with racially distinct others.
And here I do not only mean sexual relations.
My impulse to contrast human and social capital
all those years ago was rooted in my conviction
that beliefs of this kind
ultimately determine the access that people enjoy
to the informal resources required to develop
their human potential.
What I called social capital in 1976 was on this view,
a critical prerequisite for creating what economists
typically referred to as human capital.
This point again is crucial
if we're to understand the persistence
of racial inequality in America.
But what you're gonna ask yourselves,
"Is this to do with the black family?"
Well, perhaps.
Perhaps that connection is becoming clear
because the black family is the context
within which African-Americans are situated,
especially in the earliest years of life
and where these dynamics of human development
are playing out for better or for ill.
Historically oppressed groups time and again
have evolved notions of identity
that cut against the grain of their society's mainstream.
A culture can develop among them that inhibits talented
youngsters from taking the actions needed
to develop their talent.
Now, given such a situation,
I wanna ask,
do the kids in dysfunctional peer groups,
or from families that are poorly structured,
simply have the wrong utility functions
or do those communities simply have the wrong values?
Now, I wanna hold that it's a mistake
to attribute the dysfunctional behavior
of a historically oppressed group
to they're simply having the wrong preferences
when those preferences have emerged from a set of historical
experiences that reflect the largest society structures
and activities.
It's a mistake to simply blame the victim.
On the other hand,
it's also a mistake to ignore patterns of behavior
within population groups
that may inhibit their ability to take full advantage
of the opportunities that are present in their society.
You can make a mistake in blaming the victim
and you can make a mistake in looking away from the role
that the victim quote unquote might play
in his or her own bad situation.
Another way of saying this is that social relations
come before economic transactions.
When ethnic communities and their local cultures
are not integrated across boundaries of race in a society,
then racial inequality can persist,
not withstanding the enactment and effective enforcement
of laws against discrimination.
The persistence of racial disparities
derives not simply from discrimination,
but more fundamentally from the complex
morally ambiguous and difficult to regulate phenomena
that embody and reflect what people see as the meanings
given significance to their lives
and from the structure of the social connectivity
to which those meanings give rise.
All of this leads me to an important conclusion.
Namely, how a diverse society answers the question,
"Who are we?"
Is a fundamentally significant issue.
Who are we?
Whose country is it?
When we talk about crime, violence, school failure,
urban decay, or family life for that matter,
are these matters in the back of our mind
that we understand as us and them?
Because if it's us against them,
anything is possible.
It becomes possible, for example,
to say about those people languishing in the ghettos
of our great cities.
That's not my country.
That's not me.
Those aren't my people.
That's some third world thing or whatever.
I mention this because we're talking about family life.
We're talking about intimate personal relations.
I'm arguing that inequality, to some degree,
is the consequence of a failure
or a dysfunction in the family
lives of black people.
I'm a black person myself.
I don't take any pleasure in making this argument.
I feel compelled to make it.
But in doing so,
I don't wanna join a chorus of critics
who stand on the outside and point fingers
at those people and talk about their deficiencies.
I don't want to be a hypocritical moralist
who wags my finger in their faces
and tell them that they should live quote,
better close quote.
But I do wanna be a realist.
I don't wanna look away from the consequences
of the way in which many of them are,
as a matter of fact, living.
In doing so, however,
I don't wanna give license to those
who wanna wipe their hands of the matter,
turn their backs on these people who need our help,
and simply go on about their business.
And so, that's why I ask the question,
who are we here in America?
My point is that these problems,
including the problems of African-American family life,
are quintessentially an American affair
not simply a measure of the inadequacy
of black culture.
They reflect upon our social inadequacy,
I wish to argue,
and by our, I mean, all of us.
For example.
Much of the decline in the structure of African-American
family, I say decline because I mean the rise
of out of wedlock birth and the decline in the prevalence
of husband, wife households,
much of that decline,
I think, can be laid at the feet of the consequences
of American welfare policy
which has created incentives for family dissolution.
Much of it, I think,
could be laid at the feet of drifts in American culture
in which the virtues of a monogamous and a husband, wife
families has declined amongst all groups
reflected in the popular media and so forth.
Black people in the United States
are not on an island.
They live integrated within the larger social fabric.
And so, patterns of behavior that we see among them
are not simply on them,
they are also, to some degree, on us.
This is what I mean when being an economist,
I nevertheless insist on placing relations
before transactions.
What I'm talking about now,
in other words, is the American story,
not just the black American story.
Let me conclude.
Consider the poor central city dwellers
who now make up maybe a quarter
of the black American population.
The dysfunctional behavior of many in this population
is a big part of the problem here.
So, conservatives demand for greater personal responsibility
in these quarters is necessary and proper.
And yet, confronted with the despair, violence,
and self-destructive folly of so many people,
it is morally and intellectually superficial
in the extreme to argue as many have done
that those people should just get their acts together
like many of the poor immigrants.
If they did,
we wouldn't have such a horrific problem in our cities.
To the contrary, I would say,
any morally astute response to the social pathology
of American history's losers
should conclude that while we cannot change
our ignoble past,
we need not and must not be indifferent to the contemporary
consequences of it.
Their culture may be implicated in their difficulties.
But then so too, is our culture complicit in their troubles.
We, and I mean all Americans,
bear collective responsibility for the form and the texture
of our society's social relations,
and racial discrimination and racial segregation
is a part of that structure and texture.
It is also a part of the foundation for a racial inequality
in the country.
I am not talking here out of both sides of my mouth.
I insist on recognizing the importance of the family,
acknowledging the decline of structure of family
amongst African-Americans,
and owning the consequences of that decline
in terms of its contribution to racial inequality.
But I'm also not a moral infant.
I know that having recognized those social connections
and the role that they play in persisting inequality,
I have not solved the problem of what is the right thing
to do for the society as a whole.
We need to support stronger African-American families.
We need to provide the kind of support that people need
in order to be able to do their duty
and fulfill their responsibilities
in raising their children.
But we need also to insist without equivocation
that responsible parenting is the foundation for prosperity
in any society, including in this one.
And that responsible African-American parenting
is an absolute essential prerequisite
for narrowing and ultimately eliminating
the racial inequality gap in America.
Thank you.